[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de buena mañana
de miércoles vamos a abrir esta sección
del día de hoy con un reportaje
fotográfico
fotográfico publicado por el medio de
investigación el faro que dice el
régimen de excepción en el salvador
negocio y ruina
buenos días raúl exactamente este foto
reportaje se publicó hace unos días pero
hemos decidido comentarlo hoy
precisamente porque ayer se prorrogó por
tercera vez este estado de excepción en
el salvador
no sé si consideras que hace falta
contextualizar rápidamente la situación
en este país centroamericano la cuestión
es que ahí el 27 de marzo el presidente
nayib buque le decretó el estado de
excepción después de una jornada de
récord de homicidios cometidos
supuestamente por a las bandas
criminales conocidas como maras más
tarde este mismo medio que vamos a
comentar el faro reveló cómo está pues
esa jornada
en la que se cometieron decenas de
crímenes fue una especie de venganza por
parte de las maras contra el gobierno de
bucle por haber roto un pacto que tenían
digamos en medio secreto bien en todo
caso desde que buque le decidió decretar
el estado de excepción el 27 de marzo se
han detenido más de 40.000 personas en
el salvador este mismo medio el faro ha
denunciado en repetidas ocasiones
detenciones arbitrarias y también que en
este marco de estado de excepción se
está pues dando una persecución de la
prensa independiente como de los
periodistas de este medio que muchos han
abandonado el país en todo caso este
reportaje se centra en las repercusiones
económicas sobre pues la economía de los
salvadoreños de este pues estado de
excepción en primer lugar cita por un
lado casos como el de johnny no que
extiende no siempre estamos hablando de
las repercusiones sobre la microeconomía
en muchos casos informal bien johnny es
tendero y dice esto del régimen ha sido
una luz de esperanza para el negocio
bien claro qué tipo de negocio tiene
este señor este señor abrió un comercio
que ofrece ropa bebidas y comida sobre
la calle principal que conduce al centro
penal de izalco y es que evidentemente
han aumentado muchísimo la afluencia
alrededor de los centros penales dice el
texto como jon y otros han emprendido
negocios alrededor de las cárceles donde
todos los días hay madres esposas padres
en busca de información sobre el
paradero de sus familiares detenidos y
por otro lado en el caso de las familias
de los presos el régimen de excepción
perjudica la economía familiar ya de por
sí en muchos casos bastante precaria no
dice el texto en algunos casos los
familiares se ven obligados a dejar sus
últimas monedas para comprar ropa y
productos de aseo personal para sus
parientes pagar pasajes de autobús ir al
baño alrededor de los penales e incluso
alquilar un marcador para colocar el
nombre en los paquetes que ingresan a la
cárcel y estos gastos además se suman al
hecho de que muchas personas tienen que
dejar sus empleos informales para buscar
a sus hijos oa sus otros familiares en
los centros penitenciarios y como
decíamos no para algunos el régimen es
un negocio para otros una ruina y en
estas fotografías pues del texto se ve
tanto a mujeres que esperan noticias de
sus como dice angela de 55 años cada día
salen heridos y muertos de aquí tengo
que estar pendiente de mi hijo y en
muchos casos pues alquilan sillas por un
dólar por ejemplo o pues pagan 25
centavos para ir al baño o dos dólares
para que alguien cargue los paquetes
hasta la entrada de la prisión weschler
toda esta economía no pues digamos
improvisada opción alrededor exacto de
este estado de excepción pero si
continuamos en nuestro continente
americano en eeuu ayer tuvo lugar como
ya lo vimos la nueva audiencia por este
asalto al capitolio el pasado 6 enero
del año pasado 2021 el medio
especializado en política hablamos de
the hill resumió esta nueva sesión en
seis puntos no exacto y para solamente
comentarlos por encima insiste en que
trump fue el impulsor de los esfuerzos
para anular votos a bailén alegando que
habían votado personas muertas
inmigrantes irregulares que presionó a
representantes públicos para que
cambiaran los resultados electorales que
sus abogados le advirtieron que estaba
actuando de forma ilegal que no actuó
solo y que los involucrados en el plan
de los falso selectores no tuvieron en
cuenta o al menos eso declararon ante el
comité los problemas legales que podían
implicar para los funcionarios que lo
aceptaron por otro lado insiste en que
pues el panel ayer refutó las
declaraciones más enérgicas de fraude de
trampa y que el objetivo de esta
comisión es convencer a los que todavía
creen que realmente hubo fraude no esto
sobre todo de cara así pues sea donald
trump se logra volver a presentar a las
elecciones de 2024 así es rosa y como
pues recordamos también todavía estas
sesiones no han sido vinculantes digamos
para ningún organismo legal y para la
justicia hasta el momento vamos a acabar
esta revista de prensa en francia rosa
porque media par titula las gentes que
no son nada entran en la asamblea no
esto de cara también en la segunda
vuelta de las legislativas del pasado
domingo exactamente y este titular las
gentes las personas que no son nada hace
referencia a una frase que pronunció el
presidente francés emmanuel matón en
2017 recién electo por primera vez
cuando dijo que en una estación es un
lugar donde nos cruzamos con gente que
tiene éxito y personas que no son nada
no básicamente vinculando el éxito en la
vida pues con la situación económica una
situación a frase que fue pues muy
criticada y básicamente este texto
aborda el hecho que con estas
legislativas entran a la asamblea
nacional francesa pues muchas personas
que makro no considera que no son nada
no y que esto aporta pues mucha
diversidad pues a los representantes
representantes públicos del pueblo
francés se centra básicamente en tres
perfiles matt y line trabajadora
agrícola andy quebrada que es trabajador
de un call center y es el que que fue
conocida por el pueblo francés
precisamente por liderar la lucha de las
trabajadores de la cadena de hoteles
francés accord no y precisamente citan
sus declaraciones en que dice es en la
asamblea nacional que el pueblo se
expresa no es normal que no haya obreros
camareras trabajadores de la limpieza
guardias de seguridad pero no pasa nada
mi presencia va a permitirles en
referencia a la élite política adaptarse
a las profesiones esenciales rosa
muchísimas gracias como siempre por esta
revista el día de hoy mañana jueves con
más por supuesto pues vamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado al día